>>> RUSSIA'SER
OF UKRAINIAN CIVILIANS TOPOUADT
G
AUTHORITIES WHO SAY ALL OF THE
VICTIMWERE CIVILIANS
MANY OF THEMERLY AND
AS WORLD
LEADERS AREX AABOUT RUSSIAN SHE
AR POWER
PLANT. PRESIDENTD THCOULD RESUL
CHERNOBYL.
N'E SPOKE WITHOF THEIDENTS
T UNDENSULr: A UKRAINIANOM
ST MISSILE.
BUT HERE THE LUCKY ESCAP
MIS SENOVERSHOW
EM
BAMENT.
"AFT WPPENED, EVERY BOTH ROCKE B
OF A. GROUNDS
WHEN YOU S HERE, SEE
RSR E THE EDNAL COMMUNITY, ARE L
REACTIT THE MERE
THOUGHT THATD BE AT
FI
UKRAINE BLA FOR USING E NUCLEARE
SK, FOR RISK OFUCLEAR FACILITY
THE TIME TOVOKE ARMED
FORCES OF UKRAINAND TO SPREAD
AMONG THE PEOPLE
D THAT
THEIR ACTIONS. DON'T UNDERSTANDE
THE UNITED STATED
TINE HAVE ALL ED FOR RSIA TO LE
THE BOMBARDMENT OINIAN UP TOS O
IX REACTNSIFIEKED LANTNT HE CAUR
TORTURED BE ASED.W HE'S IN HIDI
EUROPE.
AND HE SAYS THPOSSIBILITOF
DISASTER IS VERY HIGH.
OPTIMIO 90%, IF E TALKING ABOUTT
I'M VERY ABOUT IT."
OCCUPIED TOWN NEXT TO THE PLANT
HAVE BEEN STUCK IN TRAFFIC JAMS,
TRYING TO FL A NUCLEAR ESCA.
UKRAINE'S CLAIMS THAN'T NUCLEASI
DO RT ASA SAFE
UKRAINE FROM
N SIDES HAVE SAID THA DRILLS I
KIND ODEMINENT, CAUSE MASSIV
RADIOACTIVAM A
M THAT COULD
R  UKRNEAR
PICTURE.E, TIS
ERE'S ALSO AECHNICAL ISSUE
HERE ENDANGERING THANUCLEA
WES THAT
RUSSIA
BROUGHT IN BY MOSC E UKRAINIACH
WHO ARCTIVELY HOSTAGES
THERE ARE ALSOUS TO STAYING ON .
T ITS PRODUC ECITY CRIMEA.IF, D